allez
un petit tour avec moi
un moment d'évasion de l'autre côté de
l'écran pour Hugo 12 ans prendre la
manette en main est un plaisir quotidien
originaire de Feucherolles adolescent
passionné de boxe aime jouer au jeu de
combat avec sa famille Super Smash Bros
ou Street of Rage 4 atteint d'une
mutation génétique sont handicap
ralenties le passage des informations
dans son corps difficulté à s'exprimer
et à se déplacer cette activité lui
permet d'être en interaction avec ses
coussins il est avec eux il est dans une
action parce que quand ils sont petits
des fois ils jouent au foot bah il peut
pas aller jouer au foot les jeux vidéo
ça fait des moments partagés ça parce
que il a pas la même vie entre dire
qu'un enfant standard de ce qui fait que
bah c'est un moment où il est un peu
comme les autres et on joue à quelque
chose comme les autres lors du
confinement en 2020 son oncle lui
rapporte une console le début de la
passion du GO pour plus accessibilité
ses parents font l'acquisition d'une
manette adaptée aux personnes en
situation du handicap d'un coup de 350
euros grandiose bouton pour remplacer
ses anciens contrôleur
Minecraft et que c'était compliqué on
avait essayé de bloquer la manette pour
pas qu'elle bouge mais les boutons sont
trop près donc on a essayé des
subterfuge on mettait des choses qu'on a
essayé des mousquetons des cordons pour
bloquer donc avec la nouvelle manette il
peut jouer à Minecraft
depuis un an tous les mercredis un
mercredi sur deux je venais chez lui et
ben on joue tous les deux et parfois il
arrive à gagner contre moi lors des
parties des environnements épurés sont
choisis par ses cousins pour permettre à
Hugo une meilleure visibilité un
divertissement permettant à l'adolescent
d'améliorer sa dextérité et son
attention
il parle avant il était un zombie qui
regardait et qui t'a fait peu sur ces
voilà je vous renvoie les premières fois
où en fait vous jouez avec lui il va y
avoir besoin de taper parce que il
fallait limite au début je joue avec lui
pour justement qui se recentre et que
les personnages ils restent dedans
maintenant c'est exceptionnel si c'est
tu es à l'extérieur c'est qu'il y a trop
de choses et que ça le perturbe en fait
et non le partage avec les autres
l'adolescent voudrait trouver un copain
pour jouer à la console avec lui si vous
aimez la bagarre Hugo se fera un plaisir
de vous défier sur ces jeux préférés
[Musique]